big chungus might be headed to
multiverses and september's games with
gold has been revealed
as spotted in a european union trademark
filing that was shared on twitter by
andrew marmo it looks like big chungus
might be headed to multiverses if you're
unfamiliar with the alternate version of
bugs bunny then what you need to know is
that the character first appeared in a
1941 looney tunes cartoon the trademark
violin for video game software doesn't
mention multiverses in its fine text but
big chungus would be a natural fit for
the game and its varied roster that
includes scooby-doo characters batman
and morty from adult swim's rick and
morty series big chungus is also canon
to looney tunes and has appeared in the
ios android game world of mayhem in 2021
and on the big screen in space jam 2.
and if you consider yourself a big fan
of space jam 2 well your sins will be
forgiven if you like this video right
now and sticking with the subject of
free games microsoft has unveiled the
next batch of monthly free games for
xbox live gold and game pass ultimate
members september's games with gold
lineup includes gods will fall double
kick heroes thrillville and portal 2.
the latter pair of games are the final
xbox 360 backwards compatible classics
that microsoft will give away via games
with gold starting in october the
service will only include games from the
xbox one era and up portal 2 is the star
of the show this september the classic
puzzle shooter is widely considered one
of the best games of its era featuring a
campaign that's roughly doubled the
length of its predecessor portal 2 added
some seriously great mechanics to the
formula if you've never played portal 2
like me do yourself a favor and check it
out when it's free in the back half of
september on the 16th prior to portal 2
landing on the service you can add
thrillville to your xbox library
throughville is an amusement park
management sim that was originally
released in 2006. if you've ever played
rollercoaster tycoon thrillville isn't
all that different but it does have an
actual narrative you can grab throw
though until september 15th all month
long subscribers will be able to claim
gods will fall an action game that was
released last year and rhythm game fans
should give double kick heroes a try
when it's up for grabs starting
september 16th this side-scrolling
action game features musical instruments
as weapons to stave off hordes of
zombies there are 24 levels with some
licensed heavy metal music that you can
work your way through or you can make
your own with the included level editor
and now i want you to hit the comments
and let me know your favorite games with
gold game of all time
it was a lot of them so if you have to
look at a list and cheat a little bit i
completely understand i can't even
remember the ones from last month
so yeah
you